yeah oh we're doing smash or pass do you
want to smash your past like who though
you
you do you want us to we don't have to
do it if you don't want yeah otherwise
what do you first notice about a girl
on the spot
carl is there more people honestly wait
like just to keep
wait really
yeah i think that's most guys they
forget to say that
i mean it's like hey you know everyone
everyone should get love but you know
certain people doesn't have to be me
a lot of guys and i was watching a lot
of fat girl got skinny videos on tick
tock and they were saying that guys
wouldn't even speak to them because they
were fat
i was like no [ __ ] dude so i tweeted
that i'm new to tweeting but like
yeah i tweeted that and a lot of guys
liked it they're like yeah we ignore
them so they don't know that we like
them yeah i mean i guess if i'm like
really like the like three times a year
i'm in a club if i'm like really got my
eyes on someone i'm you know
not gonna really be going for someone
who's overweight
but i mean i actually heard like a good
part of like game or just being sociable
in general is like make sure
not to like a large extent but like if
you're approaching like a
group of women like talk to everyone
don't just like hyper focus like one
person
you usually want to focus on the mom who
is usually the fat one and if you can
get her approval the mom of the group we
call them the ones that are
like
not like like actual pills but if you
can get their approval then you're in
the clear and they're usually very easy
to get approved because they don't get
approached often
yeah us that's also one thing it's like
you know when you date someone you also
have to date their friends
i've never heard that but i love that
it's a good because we want guys that
other women like
like we want we want i don't know yeah
like
yeah but typically like we want we want
someone that with like social status and
that's one way to show it is if her
friend's like oh then yeah first church
that's a way to yeah
yeah like that's what like you want to
date you want to date someone that
people like i mean my girlfriend always
hated my boyfriends
oh [ __ ] yeah so that's funny
that ended up [ __ ] i wish chase after
someone and then i kind of realized our
friends are [ __ ] annoying so i quit
doing it
my friends are pretty easy to get along
with i think
but they'll talk [ __ ] about you behind
your back
yeah so just when you think you're in
the clear you're uh yeah y'all stay
doing that it's like you know i'll just
leave me live my life and then rumors
come around and so
i'm going after talking about me saying
xyz i'm like
what
i think guys talk to their guy friends
about girl problems more than girls
actually go to their girlfriends to be
quite frank with you i can't refute
because i'm you know
maybe that's the problem i don't really
hang out with a lot of women so it's
like i'm just stuck doing my own thing
um
i meant dudes like you would like if you
and pearl were dating and you guys were
fighting or something
you are more inclined supposedly to go
to your guy friends for advice than
girls are to go to their girlfriends
because girls just don't even want to
tell their friends or get the it's kind
of like telling your mom
once she knows your phone
it's because yeah it's because it's like
you want the girl we don't want the
girls to like
know later
you know like if you tell if i tell
torso like i'll never
this this and this and later yeah we're
like
actually but i still do so i don't know
i know it's like telling your mom like
once you tell your mom you're [ __ ] you
know once your mom knows about justin
bieber said it the best and my mama
don't like you and she likes everyone
yeah
usually
i've been talking with like uh my guys
about like you know how it is for us
recently i just wanted like a lot of
like [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
one of my my old roommate just like
cocked one of my friends just like jesus
[ __ ] christ we cucked yeah like
well not like literally not like like
yeah i slept with uh uh other friend's
girlfriend i'm like
bruh oh no i don't know i don't mess
with that like that's [ __ ] up
yeah and if they were just all like oh
we're you know we're all drunk and i was
like
i don't know i don't i don't personally
like i don't drink anymore so it's kind
of easy for me to say but yeah
hey sometimes people it's about it
some people do black out
yeah like hardcore especially like it's
bad it's all in college so it's like i
mean
yeah at a let's say just out of school
that's uh what a pretty big game
recently so you know
our downtown on any given down uh any um
weekend it's like
partying all my friends are cutting out
and just getting blasted so it's kind of
like the it's different yeah yeah did
you say how old am i but yeah but okay
i'm 22.
okay so i actually have to try to
remember my birthday is it's okay i
forget to
like honestly when people ask me my age
i'm like 23 and then i'm like oh [ __ ] i
forgot old enough like
yeah
okay
i don't know what else to ask pearl
i feel like i know all the answers
matt calls well this is smasher pass um
did anybody call in
yeah i haven't i have a do you want to
be smashed or passed or no because if
not i'm going to go to the next person
uh
sure i mean i'm just hopping i don't
really care
okay taurus smash your pass uh
how tall are you
uh what'd you say
oh you're like a [ __ ] tree
pants
[Laughter]
you guys need to reproduce oh wait wait
wait when you said i'm a tree is that
because of height or is it like i'm also
skinny
trees aren't always skinny
i don't know
i'm a bit weird so
no you're fine
too tall though i'd have to like look up
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah that's one thing i never got it was
like you know like oh i'm just like
swiping on board i'm like oh you know i
want a guy who's like six blah blah blah
six six two six four that's why guys
they're like they're like six one i know
they're like not six one like five one
i'm like bro like
i'm here you would be like here how is
that word
that's funny i always forget you're so
short
thanks for calling in appreciate it
no problem
you didn't play oh i forgot
um
hello
how are you doing pearl how are you
doing torture how's it going
good good how are you
uh this got done working out and just
freaking practicing my japanese so it's
quite fine
that's really good